un match pour remonter dans le haut du
classement le club de poissier recevait
ce dimanche 3 décembre marli Leroi pour
le compte de la 9e journée du
championnat de D1 de district après
avoir ouvert le score les pisqués se
sont fait égaliser en seconde période un
partout un match que les joueurs locaux
auraient pu perdre mais les marlouis
n'arrive pas à conclure la rencontre se
termine par un nul bon on a fait une
bonne première mi-temps où on a su mener
au score on a concédé peu d'action
ensuite après la deè-emps était un peu
plus compliquée c'était mieux en place
on a joué moins bien on a fait moins
vivre le ballon et après bah du coup on
a concédé une sur coup de pu arrêté on a
pris un but et voilà ça fait un partout
du coup il manque les trois point à la
fin après ce résultat poissi nouveau
pensionnair de cette division après une
descente administrative occupe la 7e
place du championnat après 9 journées
disputées un classement pour l'instant
loin des ambitions du club qui espère
remonter dans les prochaines années au
niveau national la Nationale 2 c'est
loin encore d'abord passerétape D1 pour
atteindre l' R3 et après on verra étape
par étape la Nationale 2 c'est c'est
très loin pour le moment le but c'est VO
si ça remonte le plus haut possible
comme c'était dans toutes les catégories
que ça soit chez les jeunes chez les
seniors chez les filles partout c'est ça
le but du club la remontée du club au
niveau national passera déjà par un
nouveau match d' de district ce dimanche
10 décembre les pisquers recevront à
domicile le club du FC conflan les
premiers du
[Musique]
classement